Oh!
[frick x1000]
Today, we're going to make history.
Today, we're gonna save Sonic once and for all.
I know this whole Sonic thing is a little bit over done.
People have been talking about it.
I just really want to know for my own personal reason, as a fan,
how can we make Sonic right?
They decided that they're gonna fix Sonic,
I'm here to help. I'm here to give my...
Oh god....
I'm here to give my suggestions
on what that should look like.
Now first of all,
I need to find a picture.
How do I do that?
I don't want that one.
Here we go.
Okay, this looks good. High-quality picture.
God.
I think first of all I want to do what's obvious
and that's just see what he would look like as a classic look.
I know people have done this, I'm just curious.
We'll have to make the eyes smaller later.
Probably liquify isn't the best way to do this.
That's right guys. I have saved Sonic, you're welcome.
So I'm just placing it right, okay?
Look how much better that looks.
I think what I'm starting to realize here is that Sonic is a f-in cyclops.
Why is sonic a cyclops?
and why has no one questioned this earlier?
How do I do this?
I'm starting to realize maybe making a perfect sonic...
isn't so easy.
Oh my god, that is...
Very eerie, Jesus Christ.
I'm actually terrified
This will be the sonic.exe movie.
hyehyehyehyehyeh
All right next up is the mouth.
[laughing at own jokes]
(Okay, let's do the mouth)
Sonic.
What
someone ruined the sonic franchise
what so obviously the eyes are little thinner
Doesn't look really that good
Really ugly them the noses then it was looks so bad
I think it just needs to be a little more pointing and that's it. That's all they had to do
I don't have to do this bro. I'm gonna fix the nostrils because they pissed me off. They're disgusting don't give sonic nostrils
That's how you know, they messed up another error. I just realized that makes no sense
Why is the stomach and the face different color fir? Look at Sonic here. They have the same all over
Like why they never change that is that legit just a mistake
That's so stupid. Look at this how hard it is? Oh
How hard is it?
They are fixed god. Damn. This is pissing me off
It's not just the teeth it's like the whole mouth then legs there's Dee sucking lips, dude, so uncomfortable
So there you have it small details very big difference, I don't know how they mess that up
And honestly the stomach thing blows my mind because I just seems like incompetence more than anything
then design choices
Let's try out some different things, you know what they really should have done
Let's just grab a real freaking Hedgehog dub it over with some Japanese dub. Oh
And then just call it a day. Okay say this is better. This is infinitely better
It's not gonna
Dammit so awful
Panasonic is it real?
Hahaha you ever think that you just wasting your life away doing dumb pointless it well then try photoshopping
Still not worse than her it's gonna look like the past the booth me
Damn day scares me every time. Yes, that's good
Why did I waste time on this
Hey at least better than the original I had an idea in my head and now I have to execute it no matter what
Shrek Sonic is coming. Oh god is so scary Lord, forgive me for what? I'm about to do. Oh
My god, it's strange how similar their mouths are now that I think about it
I
Did a bad thing
I regret the thing I did, you know exactly what it is
I haven't done the ears yet. And it's really this is one of those things you just gotta get to
Okay. All right. God dammit. God dammit. Why?
Okay, let's look at before an actor that's always fun before after Wow
I prefer Shrek Sonic, but that's just my opinion. I
Kind of want to share see what people think about this
This is the most fun part for any artist sharing their work and see how much people enjoy it. No
No
Hey, hey spell those beams Sonic
Surprise Pikachu face Sonic what in the world Sonic golem Sonic
Why hey, all right
Dr. Phil and Sonic. Dr. Phil. I love you, and I just want to say I'm sorry. I didn't want this to happen
Someone suggested it and I realized what I had to do it
Looks so good
Running around at the speed of sound
Follow my rainbow. I'm so sorry everyone
Good
God I don't know why it's so funny. It's not
Oh
God let's see what people think of dr. Phil Shani
Stop why Nicolas Cage sonic is a classic. Of course, you gotta go fast to the ranch
Get to the ranch even faster. All right, I think that's enough. I had a lot of fun
let me know what update of sonic you want to see in the sonic fix and
That's it for me for now
Smash like subscribe check out merch check out tuber simulator and see you guys out a hundred mil
That was we brofist for a hundred men. Let's get it
What you never played to purr simulator
You know, it's fun right? I'm not supposed to give my opinion
But give it a try and then you can tell me if it's good or not not convinced yet. Okay. I'll cut you a deal
The game is available for free and that's a great price
Spongebob sonic isn't real